can you successfully follow up one of
the most beloved comic book movies of
all time is it possible to make a dude
with teeny Wings on his feet and little
green shorts look cool the answer is
that yes you can but not without a few
compromises along the way warning Major
Spoilers for black panther wakanda
forever ahead
costume designer Ruth e Carter who
became the first black woman ever to win
the Oscar in the category for her work
on the first black panther has really
outdone herself this time with her
return in Black Panther wakanda forever
the costumes in wakanda Forever range
from college kids streetwear to
high-tech diving suits to ceremonial
funeral Garb and so much more Queen
raimonda's Mini Royal ensembles or
standouts in various shades of jewel
tones from form-fitting to billowing her
gowns all still share the same design
Motif thanks to similar prints and
coordinating jewelry nakia's bright and
casual clothes from her scenes is a
Haitian teacher suit the character's
personality just as much as her vibrant
greenish War Dog armor and the
incredible quality of Neymar's movie
specific design does much of the work of
transforming the character from a long
time Comics Oddball into a mythical
anti-hero god the outfits are all
visually interesting yet believe a and
how they pull inspiration from real
culture ancient and modern is
commendable she really can make you like
click
s with the costume she puts you in she's
a Storyteller for
usually if the camera is going to linger
on a particular shot in an MCU film it's
because of fight choreography or
expensive CGI in wakanda Forever the
camera frequently lingers on characters
just looking awesome in their clothes
Carter's Creations are that breathtaking
while none of the designs in wakanda
Forever are misses the fleet of vehicles
in the film is probably the weakest
element conceptually on their own all
the modes of transportation range from
fine to pretty cool for instance the
aircraft that arrives to transport to
chala's vibranium coffin almost
resembles the face of a black panther
when it's lit up and viewed from below
which is an interesting visual touch but
when it actually levitates the casket up
in its tractor beam during the funeral
it completely takes viewers out of
what's an otherwise serious somber
moment meanwhile some of the other
planes that are deployed to evacuate
citizens during the flooding of wakanda
look vaguely and curiously like simpler
versions of Nova core Starships from the
Guardians of the Galaxy even the large
wakandan ship that serves as the main
Battleground for the film's final fight
feels kind of boring and unmemorable
wakanda forever's vehicles feel marvely
they're just not the sleekest or most
exciting that the MCU has to offer
wakanda forever confronts heavy and
pressing Global issues head-on the film
can be read as a metaphor for nuclear
proliferation the wakandans possess the
world's most powerful resource and
everyone else is in a race to catch up
in the past real civilizations like Nazi
Germany or the Soviet Union have been
the antagonists in Marvel films this
time it's modern America France and the
rest of the United Nations being
outgunned by a small African country has
exposed the West's hypocrisy new CIA
director Valentina Allegra de Fontaine
openly admits she dreams about the U.S
controlling Earth's vibranium Supply but
a large chunk of the international
intelligence Community is willing to
resort to some pretty villainous tactics
to get that sweet magic medal at a
United Nations meeting Queen ramonda
dramatically announces that wakanda has
foiled a plot to steal vibranium from
one of their secret research facilities
by having the Dora milaje March the
captive offenders before their heads of
state she argues it's not vibranium's
power she fears but what humans would do
with it it's a bold move to call out
these nations this way but it works with
the story wakanda forever is trying to
tell the sequel is also interested in
colonialism and its effects on
indigenous people in a flashback we see
that Spanish conquistadors brought ruin
to Neymar's people his anger at and
distrust of the surface World stems from
The Fallout even the film's resolution
in which two super-powered beings agree
to put Vengeance aside and de-escalate
their fight plays into the nuclear
symbolism in The Real World Cold War
policy of mutually assured destruction
wakanda forever's politics aren't left
or right they're clear-eyed and
practical
Dominique Thorne is a likable addition
to the MCU as Riri Williams AKA
ironheart but the plot that introduces
her isn't as good as the character
herself or Thorne's performance it's
entertaining and gives wakanda forever
some propulsion early on but it's also
underbaked that can't be good riri's
vibranium detecting school project ends
up in the hands of covert U.S operatives
who are using it to find heretofore
unknown quantities of vibranium from a
seabed in the Atlantic Ocean this
interference threatens Neymar and his
people's way of life and kicks off the
conflict between Neymar and wakanda
Neymar wants to kill the scientists who
made the machine while shuri is
determined to protect Riri unfortunately
riri's actual involvement in the story
doesn't amount to much there's a fun
moment early on where she helps Sharia
nokoye escape the local police with the
help of her homemade ironheart suit but
after that she's little more than a plot
football part hardly anything she does
from this point forward affects the
events of the film her more polished
Iron Heart armor helps shuri's plan to
trap Neymar in the final battle but her
character's motivations aren't much more
than don't die helpful wakanda the movie
keeps trying to tell us that she'll be
important with a few hints of her
backstory but we rarely see that
importance take shape like America
Chavez and Dr Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness Riri is an exciting new
character with tons of potential who's
reduced mostly to a human MacGuffin
one of the smartest decisions Ryan
coogler and company made was swapping
Marvel Comics Atlantis for the mythical
Mesoamerican city of telokon a
fictionalization of talocon one of the
Aztec afterlives of course the decision
was more or less made for them since
Warner Brothers beat Marvel to the
screen with Aquaman never mind that
Neymar came first in the comics Aquaman
has always been the better known
Half-Blood king of Atlantis wakanda
forever changed that bit of Neymar's
backstory and it works wonderfully in
the film version his origin story has
everything to do with a vibranium
meteorite and Spanish conquistadors
rooting Namor in Aztec and Mayan history
and culture is a vast Improvement on an
already intriguing Comics character and
the telecon that the filmmakers created
for him Rivals wakanda born with
prolonged life and the ability to
breathe air and water as well as the
gift of flight because of the Wings on
his feet Namor is given the title kukul
Khan or feather serpent God a
supernatural entity pulled from
Mesoamerican religion as a boy he
becomes a legend to his people when he
uses his power to fight back against
Spanish colonizers since the MCU has
been interested in geopolitical issues
and gods lately this updated version of
Neymar and his home of telecon fits
right into the Cinematic universe's
trajectory
koye became one of the breakout
characters in Black Panther for good
reason the leader of the doer milaje was
as stoic and tough as anyone in the
first film say for t'challa himself her
storyline saw her wrestle with the
question of what to do when killmonger
assumed the throne though dinagarira is
every bit as captivating in wakanda
Forever the film doesn't do her justice
she gets a stunning entrance when the
Dora milaje infiltrate the French
operatives planning to steal and study
vibranium but for much of the second
half of the movie She's M.I.A when shuri
and Riri are captured ramonda blames
Okoye and dismisses her from Duty
devastated one of the best characters
and best actors in the film is sidelined
in a movie with way too many characters
to fully develop it's a shame that one
of the franchise's best doesn't get
enough screen time to continue her own
fascinating story
in the comics Neymar and black panther
have a real love-hate relationship
sometimes they align themselves and
their kingdoms with each other for a
common cause and they are both
superhuman rulers of super secret
societies but more often than not
they're at each other's throats with
wakanda forever somebody other than
t'challa had to put on The Black
Panther's mask and face off against
Neymar though Chadwick Boseman and tanak
Huerta would have been phenomenal scene
partners aweta and Leticia writes shuri
have a totally different chemistry that
takes Neymar and the Black Panthers love
hate relationship to another level in
this adaptation there's actually some
romantic tension between the mutant god
king and the scientist princess it's
never made explicit except for that
pretty high value gift of his Beloved
Mother's bracelet when Namor offers to
take Sharita talukan and wistfully
confides in her that she's the first
surface human ever to have seen their
world it's not hard to imagine them as
Allah and maybe something more there's a
tragic irony to the idea that these two
understand each other but are destined
to become enemies for a time at least
when rimanda orders Nakia to invade his
home and she kills some of his people to
rescue shuri he retaliates by flooding
wakanda and indirectly killing many
citizens including ramonda herself even
their final showdown is charged with
shared emotion they're both isolated
angry and as Neymar's name means in this
take on the character without love but
if only broken people can be great
leaders there are big things ahead for
Neymar and shuri together or not both
nations want the same thing which is to
preserve and to protect their people but
they're willing to go by different ways
when the MCU first took us to wakanda
viewers got to meet a plethora of new
characters including more people of
color and more women than the franchise
had ever seen before in addition to
t'challa his Supporting Cast all had
unique fleshed out personalities of
their own wakanda forever advertised
that audiences would become acquainted
with a second super-powered civilization
the trailers and casting news indicated
that atuma and nomura two important
characters from the comics would be
living and fighting alongside Namor just
as a koye and umbaku did in Black
Panther in the comics atuma is a
barbarian-like Atlantean who believes
that he ought to rule instead of Namor
and throughout her comics history nomura
has been everything from neymore's
implied lover to his cousin to a clone
even with the change from Atlantis to
telecon there is enough backstory to
have made a Tuma and the Mora more
unique characters instead one of wakanda
forever's weak spots is the regrettable
underdevelopment of his telecono
Supporting Cast there deployed much like
Infinity Wars ebony Ma and Proxima
midnight like a henchman and henchwoman
who are little more than bodies in the
way until it's time for the main
characters to fight Neymar we get little
more than a hint that nomura is
dissatisfied with Namor and shury's
peaceful resolution near the end
it's become a refrain that most Marvel
movies are great until the Final Act
evolves into a CGI soup the main
ingredients of which are faceless hordes
Kaiju like Monsters and of course Sky
beams and portals most of the criticism
of the first black panther in fact came
for its lackluster last act digital
effects it seems the filmmakers have
learned from their mistakes and from
worn out MCU tropes the final battle in
wakanda Forever is one of Marvel Studios
shorter and smaller scale scuffles but
in terms of relevance to the plot and
visual style it's a breath of fresh air
Sherry finally steps into a leadership
role as the Black Panther literally
standing as the Vanguard of her troops
atop a massive military vessel they're
planning to lure Namor to them so they
can trap him into a retrofitted aircraft
that will dry him out and deplete his
powers just as Namor is his people's god
of the air Land and Sea this climactic
conflict unfolds in the sky sand and on
the Atlantic Riri Williams gleefully
buzzes through the clouds in her tricked
out ironheart suit shuri crashed lands
on the shore and the Black Panther and
The Feathered Serpent God slash at each
other acrobatically in the sand and
Flames the Dora milage used cables to
take on the teleconil in an impressively
choreographed vertical assault while the
Jabari defend the deck it's perfect for
the story that wakanda forever is trying
to tell which is about how war is rarely
in a nation's best interest
this might sound like a backhanded
compliment but the mcu's Namor looks way
cooler than anyone who's familiar with
Comics probably expected in his earliest
Illustrated form Namor looks like a turn
of the century muscle man in a belted
Speedo and then there's the matter of
those pointy elf ears and those little
angelic wings that grow out of his feet
even after Namor got an emo makeover in
the 2000s writers and artists still had
to contend with those quirks as did Ryan
coogler in wakanda forever as per usual
the writer director was up to the task
Namor is one of the highlights of the
movie my enemies call me no more
in part that's thanks to the casting of
tenoch Huerta and his performance which
ranges from endearing to frightening and
in part that's thanks to the character's
new backstory and status as an
indigenous Mexican god king Neymar still
has his skimpy green shorts but the
costume has been redesigned with Native
iconography and materials somehow even
the image of the mutant hovering in
place is Tiny foot Wings flapping fast
isn't ridiculous all of this is an
enormous accomplishment considering how
often Namor looks silly in the comic
books and how serious wakanda forever is
for most of its run time the only
moments in which it's hard to take the
movie and its anti-hero seriously come
when the mutant Leaps and Bounds through
set pieces like Legolas doing parkour or
when he uses his winged feet to dash
across the sky not unlike a hummingbird
CGI has come a long way but it still
can't make superhuman Feats like that
look very natural
[Music]